Believe it or not, The Lost Boys was originally
supposed to be a more wholesome, Peter Pan-inspired
vampire movie. But following the success of
St. Elmo's Fire, director Joel Schumacher
turned the project into a sexy, gory, and
politically subversive teenage classic that
changed the way vampires would be portrayed
in Hollywood for decades to come.
While it still holds up as one of the better
vampire films ever made, there's probably
a lot you don't know about this cult classic.
So grab your leather jacket, hold onto the
rails, and check out the untold truth of The
Lost Boys.
Santa Carla
You don't have to be from California to know
that Santa Carla, the town where The Lost
Boys takes place, doesn't actually exist.
However, locals can easily recognize The Lost
Boys' location as the South Bay beach town
Santa Cruz, thanks to shots of its Giant Dipper
Roller Coaster.
Director Joel Schumacher fell in love with
the locale as soon as he scouted it, telling
the local news, "The movie didn't come together
until I saw [Santa Cruz]. At the time, there
was an enormous amount of transient kids moving
through Santa Cruz. This is exactly where
I would come if I was a teenage vampire."
After reversing a couple of letters in nearby
Santa Clara, he even had a locally inspired
new name for his movie's dream spot.
The cast enjoyed filming in the scenic beach
town, too. Corey Feldman recalled, "We had
such a great time there. Being kids and having
the opportunity to be at the Boardwalk every
day, getting to ride on the Giant Dipper and
being at the beach, it was such a fun experience."
However, securing Santa Cruz as the film's
location wasn't all smooth sailing. The town's
authorities were wary of the Boardwalk being
portrayed in a bad light, especially after
1983's violent Sudden Impact took them by
surprise. Even worse, Santa Carla's title
as "the murder capital of the world" wasn't
fictional, as Santa Cruz earned that description
after years of serial killings. But the authorities
read The Lost Boys' script, loved it, and
ended up giving Schumacher the green light.
And the rest is pop culture history.
Goonies gone vampire
The Lost Boys was initially skewed towards
a much younger audience. The film's original
script, written by Jan Fischer and James Jeremias,
was intended to be — as the title suggests
— a re-imagining of Peter Pan with vampires.
However, as Schumacher told the Telegraph,
he thought it read too much like "The Goonies
go vampire," especially with Goonies director
Richard Donner originally at the helm and
Corey Feldman joining the cast.
When Donner departed the project to direct
Lethal Weapon, Schumacher gained control and
took The Lost Boys from "very wholesome" to
very campy.
He explained, "The Frog brothers were Boy
Scouts. I thought, 'Why can't they all be
teenagers? Why can't they be dressed incredibly?
And why can't they have stripped-down motorcycles
that look skeletal?'"
Schumacher posed these questions to Warner
Bros. president Mark Canton, who ultimately
gave him permission to give the script a teenage
makeover.
Alex Winter, who played Marko, praised the
changes, saying, "I don't think I really connected
with it until I got there and realized quite
how deep Joel was going. He really got it
cinematically and was taking it to this crazy
place."
Edgar Rambo
Thanks to his connection with Goonies director
Richard Donner, Corey Feldman received an
invitation to audition for the part of The
Lost Boys' vampire-slaying Edgar Frog. But
when he read through the script with Joel
Schumacher, he got an interesting note:
"He was like, 'That was great but could you
maybe, um, butch it up a little bit?'"
Feldman said he was instructed to hit the
video store and rent the movies of Sylvester
Stallone and Chuck Norris, telling him:
"That is your character. I want you to meld
all of these guys together and make something
out of it."
Feldman's portrayal of Edgar Frog certainly
breathes some comedic life into the film,
which is often pretty dark and serious.
Of that Feldman said, "I think the fun part
about the character and the comic value of
it is that he doesn't think it's funny, and
he's not in on the joke. So, [he's] one of
those people that you just kinda have to laugh
at because, you know, they really take themselves
very seriously, and they believe every word
of what they're saying about themselves, or
whatever it is they believe in."
Challenging conventions
The Lost Boys may be campy, but it also challenged
certain common conventions about family life
in America.
The Atlantic argues that the movie arrived
at a time when many Americans were fearful
of a perceived disintegration of the traditional
nuclear family structure.
The Lost Boys challenged these notions by
focusing on two non-traditional families — the
Emersons and the vampire crew. As 'the good
guys,' the Emersons survive — and ultimately
thrive — despite the mother being newly
divorced, broke, and forced to move into her
father's house with her two sons. When we
meet Max — the one father-type character
who could offer a traditional fix to the broken
Emerson family — it turns out he's also
a monster. Meanwhile, the film's other family
is a bunch of dudes living, sleeping, partying,
and killing together.
Additionally, the film is also commonly analyzed
as challenging conservative notions of sexuality,
all at a time when the President of the United
States was accused of ignoring the country's
incredibly serious AIDS crisis.
Today, much of The Lost Boys is commonly viewed
as homoerotic. Santa Carla itself represents
a place where people on the outskirts of society,
such as homosexuals and vampires, can live
openly. David and his crew of vampires dress
in leather outfits not unlike to those worn
by members of the early '80's underground
gay club scene, and new vampires must drink
David's blood in an initiation ceremony. Sam's
bedroom is decorated with a poster of Rob
Lowe's abs. Michael, fearing his actions with
David have led him down a deviant path, rushes
off to have sex with Star — whom none of
the other vampires seem particularly interested
in.
Schumacher himself even endorses these analyses,
telling GamesRadar that "[The Lost Boys] is,
in a way, about the fear we have of the Other—those
who live outside of the mainstream."
All about Michael
Anyone who's ever even passively watched The
Lost Boys has the name "Michael" permanently
engraved in their memories of the movie. That's
because the protagonist's name is uttered
more than any other word in the entire film.
Just how many times do we hear his name? Well
over a hundred.
"Michael! Michael! Michael! Michael! Michael!
Michael! Michael!"
Considering the film's runtime is only 97
minutes, that means viewers got at least one
Michael-mention a minute, which is a lotta
name love for one half-vampire to receive.
A Tale of Two Coreys
Child stars Corey Haim and Corey Feldman were
a late '80s dynamic duo, appearing together
in pics like License to Drive, Dream a Little
Dream, and National Lampoon's Last Resort.
But it was The Lost Boys that first paired
the young actors who'd later be referred to
as "the two Coreys."
"We just clicked. Uh, chemistry for ourselves,
and people I guess get wind of it. Like 'Wow,
these two have something off camera but on
camera.'"
Unfortunately, a series of ill-advised personal
and professional decisions derailed both Coreys'
careers, and their brief peak as teenage heartthrobs
belied a slew of direct-to-video releases.
Sadly, even their on-screen reunion on the
short-lived reality show The Two Coreys couldn't
save Corey Haim, who passed away in 2010 at
the age of 38.
Ben Stiller, Lost Boy?
Kiefer Sutherland's crew of leather-wearing
teenage vampires with rock 'n' roll haircuts
almost included another up-and-comer we all
know now.
Ben Stiller has claimed that he was almost
cast as one of the Lost Boys, telling a Hollywood
crowd in 2010, "Last time I saw a room full
of so many talented faces was when I auditioned
for The Lost Boys. It was between me and Kiefer
and the two Coreys."
He might've been joking, but the actor would
have been 21 at the time of production, which
makes him the right age for one of the roles.
It's also fairly easy to imagine the dark-haired
Stiller wearing leather and riding a motorcycle
alongside Sutherland and crew. Considering
all the models that did make into the cast,
it's also easy to picture Zoolander's patented
"Blue Steel" pose stacking up against Brooke
McCarter's tough-guy smirk quite nicely.
Stolen fiancée
While filming The Lost Boys, Jason Patric
and Kiefer Sutherland became close friends.
Four years later, however, Patric was on an
airplane to Ireland with Sutherland's ex-fiancée,
Julia Roberts, leading to some juicy tabloid
drama.
In 2016, Sutherland reflected on the headline-making
breakup from years earlier:
"We were young and we were both very much
in love, and we had decided that we wanted
to get married… She was arguably the most
famous woman in the world… This wedding
that was supposed to be something between
the two of us became something so big… I
think she had the courage — it wasn't what
she wanted to do in the end."
Not long after her split with Sutherland,
however, Roberts started dating Patric. For
his part, Patric has since downplayed the
whole love triangle ordeal, telling Vulture,
"everything that happened was all fake and
bulls--- and let them give quotes about whatever
they want. Obviously people are gonna ask.
They had a relationship that ended and I was
with her for a little while and it ended.
They've both been subsequently married several
times and I think they're fine. But we never
had any issue, even back then."
Indeed, to this day, Patric claims he has
maintained his friendship with Sutherland,
despite their brief romantic rivalry.
"It's just nice that all these years later,
I'm still very good friend with Jami Gertz,
very good friends with Kiefer. And, it was
a special time."
Buffy the vampire stealer
As one of the first teenage vampire films
to feature some serious sex appeal, The Lost
Boys inspired a whole new sub-genre of vampire
stories — including Buffy the Vampire Slayer.
Buffy creator Joss Whedon has gone on record
to explain some of the ways his movie and
resulting TV series took inspiration from
the film. As Whedon told Salon back in 2003,
"the idea of [vampires] looking like monsters
and then looking like people … That was
in Lost Boys, and that was very useful for
us. … You could have somebody fool you,
or someone like Angel seem like he's not a
vampire and then he is one."
The series' second season introduced a character
named Spike, a platinum blonde vampire played
by James Marsters. Whedon credited The Lost
Boys for the inspiration for the character,
saying "there's a little Billy Idol, a little
Kiefer Sutherland in The Lost Boys, and every
guy in a black coat."
Skip the sequels
Although The Lost Boys lives on as a piece
of cultural iconography, its sequels definitely
failed to earn the same kind of hype.
Why? Well, the first sequel took 20 years
to happen, and even then it was still a straight-to-DVD
sort of deal. Titled Lost Boys: The Tribe,
the movie did bring back Corey Feldman as
the only original cast member who made it
into the final cut. And while it features
plenty of vampires and topless women, it has
almost nothing to do with the original film,
leading critics to unanimously label it as
little more than a cheap cash grab.
It did manage to make back its production
costs upon release, however, so Warner Bros.
gave the go ahead to another titled Lost Boys:
The Thirst, featuring the reunion of Feldman
and Jamison Newlander as the Frog brothers.
However, it was slaughtered by critics and
sold half as many DVDs as the first sequel
… so consider this one a lost boy in its
own right.
Thanks for watching! Click the Looper icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel. Plus
check out all this cool stuff we know you'll
love, too!